[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Hey.
>> Hi, Jeffrey.
>> Hi, how are you?
>> We're doing good, everybody's excited.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Thank you so
much for coming all the way up from LA.
We appreciate the visit.
>> Excited to be here.
>> We're very excited to have you.
That was an incredible
list of accomplishments,
and you started off
without getting a degree.
Can you tell us why?
>> I will, but I actually.
I've always found in speaking
in front of any groups,
it's actually valuable for me to know
a little bit about the audience.
And so, if I could just do a really
quick survey of how many forms are there
here that are headed to Vegas tonight,
could I see a show of hands?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Boy.
>> So, I would just want to give you sort
of two things that I might be able
to help you out on the first is
likely probably not a lot of people
in this room that could give
you wardrobe advice as to how to dress for
the 1970s.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I actually can do that,
I have knowledge and experience there.
And probably more importantly than that.
You should know that right around
the corner from the marquee club at
the cosmopolitan,
is the best pizza in Las Vegas.
It's called Secret Pizza.
It is a secret, but now there are couple
of hundred of view that know the secret.
It's open till 5:00 AM, which is
I'm sure right around the time and
which you'll be wanting and on some pizza.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, I did not go to college.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> The interesting thing that I
partnered in 1994 with Steven Spielberg
and David Gavin, the three of us do,
actually do not have a college degree,
so whatever that's worth for [LAUGH].
I didn't go to college,
because I actually started working.
Very young as a teenager
I had volunteered for
a man who ran for
mayor of New York City, John Lindsay,
who had been a Congressman
on the Upper East Side.
And Lindsay was really
an incredibly charismatic,
very forward thinking, very, I think
engaging and thoughtful,
unique liberal politician.
And came in a time and
an era where participating, and
giving, and being involved in.
Civic, you know was pretty powerful,
you know, the late sixties were,
you know,
a time of a lot of civil rights movements
changing moments in our culture and
our society, and being there
in politics,
in government was a very exciting thing.
And I started very young as a teenager,
and continued to work, and
when that moment,
I actually did go to college for a moment.
I registered at NYU, because it was
the closest college to City Hall.
And in that era you only had
to hand your class card in,
and then show up for exams, so it was
pretty easy for me to go to college.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I think the first, in 1970,
the first mid term exam
overlapped with the first
police strike in a modern city in America.
[LAUGH] The police went on
strike in New York City,
which had never happened before.
And I thought, I could do better
there than in a college classroom,
and that was the end of my college career.
>> [LAUGH] What did you
learn from those years that you've
taken interior career later?
>> Everything, I mean, it was just,
it was a lessons in life.
And about people, and values, and
seen the harsh realities
of the streets of New York,
and the goods, and bads, and the uglies.
And honestly there's not in those five,
or six, seven years that I worked for
the mayor, I actually saw everything.
I was a advance man for
the mayor and who loved to be
on the streets of New York,
felt that he should be there whenever,
wherever anything exceptional,
or extraordinary was happening,
and it required the resources of
government to be there and respond.
So, every time and anytime anything
bad happened, he wanted to show up and
make sure the government
was there doing its job.
So, whether it's a tenement would
burn down, or subway accident, or
a police officer shot in the line of duty,
or you know what a main breaker.
Anything that was at all disruptive,
he felt as the leader of the city,
he should be there front and
center to see that the city did it's job.
And so, for me as an advance man,
it pretty much put me in the wrong place
at the wrong time, pretty much everyday.
So, you'll learn about amazing,
amazing things about life and death, and
moments of happiness, and
sacrifice and just everything.
It's just the entire rainbow of colors
of everything around life
reflected in those experiences.
And I think, they that's served me very
well and they matured me in a way,
and they gave me a confidence
about of myself.
I think which was unique and
for somebody so young.
I had these life experiences
at an extremely early age.
>> And a sense of responsibility as
a leader that would [CROSSTALK].
>> Yeah, you could make a difference.
This idea that you know,
you can't change the course of things.
I don't buy that of anything, but
particularly, I think that, and
even today I think about it,
people feel like, well, if you don't
like something, what do you do about it?
And I would say, well,
you have two things.
And they are invaluable, and
I think, we tend not to understand how
important and how valuable they are.
It's your voice and your vote.
And so, right now, today,
we're sort of going sideways here.
For me in politics today, I don't think
there's ever been a more important time in
which we have to exercise our voice and
our vote.
And we have elections that
are coming up later this year.
We have elections that are coming up in
a little more than two and a half years.
And for me in terms of what
I'm more focus on it than
anything else today is I
would love to see this next
election cycle, these next two
election cycles particularly 2020.
I would like to see a participation and
a turnout in our democracy,
the lives of which our country
has never experienced before,
because the stakes have never been higher.
And so, through this one in particular,
there's nothing more important than voter
registration and voter participation.
It is the foundation.
Of our democracy, and it is a choice.
It is a moment in time in which we
actually get to determine the course of
our country and our leaders.
And we only have ourselves to thank or
blame for where we are.
Go vote.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> So that call to foster expression and
to hear voices,
is that what brought you into Hollywood?
>> No, I wanted [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> No, I was 22-years-old.
And so Lindsay ran for president in 1972.
I worked in Wisconsin and Florida,
which were the two primaries.
When he lost in those primaries and
went back to city government,
I did not want to go
back to city government.
because I felt like I had done
everything that I could do, and
I wanted a new challenge.
At 22-years-old, I really had sort of
risen as far as was
practical in government.
I don't think I was going to get made
police commissioner or fire commissioner.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And so I wanted to go find a career
in an industry where at least
age would not pull me back.
And many people said go
look at entertainment.
Look at the movie business
because it is a place
in which youth is actually
a valued asset not a liability.
And so that that is actually
sort of the the big idea of why.
And I got a couple little opportunities.
But then I had the really great
fortune of meeting this amazing,
amazing person, Barry Diller,
who invented something
called Movies of the Week,
which we don't have anymore in TV.
But he was real both creative and
an entrepreneur.
And he had just been made the chairman
Paramount Pictures at the age
of 34-years-old,
which was rather extraordinary.
And Barry hired me as his gofer,
which I think when I went to work for
him I was 23.
And then over the course of the next
11 years that I worked at Paramount and
I worked for Barry,
he did one of the most amazing things,
which is he really genuinely mentored me.
He invested in me.
He believed in me.
And he in a very, really sort of
almost thoughtful, methodical way.
I didn't understand it at the time, but he
had me work in every area of the company.
And so by the time I was 29-years-old,
and I'd worked for six years.
I was in marketing, and
distribution, and international, and
negative pickups, and TV.
I had all these experiences where I would
work for a year or so in one of these, and
then he'd move me into something else.
And I didn't see any
grand plan here in this.
I was just getting moved
around a bit [LAUGH].
But when I was 29-years-old, 30-years-old,
he made me president of the studio.
And I actually could do the job.
And the only reason I could do the job
is because he had taken the time
to actually train me and give me
the resources to function in the job.
>> Can you tell us a little bit about
a day in the life as the head of a studio?
>> Well, yeah,
I'll focus just maybe narrowly on
movies because that was what
I was doing at Paramount.
When I went to Disney, it was sort
of a broader job because it involved
television, and animation, and
much wider responsibilities.
But at Paramount,
running a studio really is about
finding great ideas and
finding great talent.
Creating a great environment for
people to be able to pursue and
realize dreams,
even though those dreams, in many cases,
are anywhere between improbable and
impossible.
And to create an environment where
people have the ability to fail and
to take risk.
And the reason for
that is that great stories,
great movie telling, is at its
best when its original and unique.
And if you sort of think about it
almost as a mathematical equation,
original and unique equals risky, right.
It's not a proven formula.
And risky equals,
at least to some degree, failure.
So if you don't allow some failure in
the equation, you're not going to have
people do things that are risky and
unique, that are unique and original.
And if you don't have unique and original,
everything becomes derivative and
I think uninspired, and
you won't have success.
So creating a great environment for
people to take that appropriate amount
of risk and to actually be able
to have the ambition to do things
that sometimes aren't going to work.
Now, very specifically,
I don't, maybe it came from those years.
I have an insane work ethic and habit,
and I get up very early in the morning.
As some people may have heard, I have
multiple breakfasts, multiple lunches,
multiple dinners.
And how about that, right.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So that's genetic,
I can thank my parents for that.
I sleep five hours a night,
I thank my parents for that.
I don't get jet lag,
This is all in the gene pool.
I have nothing to do with it.
If you only sleep five hours a night,
which I have done since
I was 15-years-old.
The Beatles actually wrote a song for me.
It's called Eight Days a Week,
>> [LAUGH]
>> That was for me, anyway.
>> So I got an extra day, and
I manage my time, I invest my time.
Nobody's ever actually asked me, so
why do you have all these breakfasts,
lunches and dinners?
I'm going to tell you,
including some of my partners who
are sitting here in front of me.
I have found, as a head of a studio,
there's a very great distance
between you and talent and artists.
And, again, there's a little bit of fear.
And as you grow,
both in the job that you have, but
also reputationally, and
they create mythology around you.
And coming to see me over the years,
it started to get to the point
where it's like going to see Oz.
It scares you to death.
And I found that the way
to take that out of
the equation was across
a table with a meal.
And that suddenly,
just the relaxed nature of sitting at
a table with somebody coming and
bringing food, and eating,
just gave me an ability to connect
with people way, way, way better
than I could across a desk in an office or
sitting on the other side of a couch.
And so
I just found that I'm way more productive.
And so I would get up and
I would have breakfast at six, seven,
eight in the morning.
All three of those by the way, [LAUGH].
So in the studio,
a typical Monday morning,
we would, the first thing we would do,
is have a weekend read.
So probably,
maybe the most important valuable thing as
an executive that you have to do is read.
And I think that all great
movies start with a great idea.
All great ideas must have a great story.
And so reading is essential.
And I will tell you just how demanding
it was as a typical week for
me when I was at Paramount is
I would actually read ten or
12 screenplays a week, and
I'm not a superfast reader.
I'm dyslexic, and so
I actually have to read a little slow.
And so it would take me almost
two hours to read a screenplay.
And I used to actually come start at
6 o'clock on Saturday morning and
read till 5,
6 o'clock in the afternoon and
then comeback probably do about
half of that on a Sunday for years.
I mean years and years, and years I have
read thousands of screenplays literally.
And so then on Monday morning, we all
would come in and we would actually talk
about what we read and what were the good
ideas, and who were the great writers.
And then you would move
through the day and
there would be things about
meeting with filmmakers, and
hearing what their take on their
story was, why they wanted to do it.
And then kind of through the process
of a movie of everything
from assembling the team around it,
the producers,
the directors, the casts,
pretty much every element of it.
Where was it going to be done,
the budget, the marketing.
So these are all elements of movie making.
And they're still kind
of relevant today and
it's probably organize a little
bit differently today.
But, certainly back then,
that was what a day was for me.
And we have previews of our movies,
we always found a great collaboration with
our audience when we'd have a movie
that was a work in progress.
Having that moment where a filmmaker or
a storyteller could actually
hear an audience in that sort of just
natural involuntary response to a film and
to see was it going too fast,
was it going too slow, was it confusing?
That's just just sitting in the back of an
audience, it's not about sort of testing,
it's not about sort of filling out preview
cards which I'm sure everybody is done,
that stuff kind of nonsense.
But just sitting in
an audience you can tell so
much about things that are working and
things that are not working.
>> You've described your work ethic and
giving all Saturday,
part of Sunday, making work your life.
Have you seen that have a really
strong impact on the teams around you?
How has that evolved for you?
>> Well, it's fortunate of all, because I
started off sort of I guess neanderthal,
because I actually once
said a number of years ago,
if you don't come to work on Saturday,
don't bother coming on Sunday.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Now, here's the problem with that.
When I said it I meant it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
the lessons that I learned, I think,
anybody learns is that you
learn that working smarter
sometimes has as much value
as working harder And
you also learn that having
what is sort of popularly
referred to as sort of work-life balance
is not just a nice theoretical thought.
I think it's actually true.
And so I can kid all I want about it, but
the fact is I have a wonderful family,
I have been married for
45 years to an amazing,
amazing partner, have 2 kids, 3 grandkids.
Very proud of how my kids grew up and
how they became people,
and found their own identity and
their own careers.
And that became an important part of it,
and so in my 20s, that was probably fine.
It's probably fine for all of you.
But there's a moment in time in which you
actually have to find those things that
make you whole as a human being and
then make you better at what you're doing.
And so having that element as
an important part of your life is,
I think,
an invaluable asset of doing a great job.
>> As the boss respecting that in
your team, in the team around you and
what you're building.
>> Have to, yeah.
>> So if we move into he Disney years,
everyone has a favorite child.
So do you have a favorite
film from that time?
>> [LAUGH]
>> There are different
movies that have different.
So, first of all,
the other genetic defect I have and
addition to those others that I gave you
is that I don't have a reminiscent gene.
And so, I tend not to look back.
And most of all when
something's finished for
me I turn the chapter and
I go to the next thing.
And so, at least to date, I've not yet
found that moment to turn back and
actually be reflective in a way about it.
But there are things and stories
that I have told over the years that
had a connection to me, because I had
something to do with the idea itself,
and the idea was in some way a reflection
of something going on for me.
I say that and I want to wave the flag
of saying, I had some peace in that,
because I don't want to take
credit from great writers,
great directors, great filmmakers
whose names are on these things.
Sam Goldwyn who is one of
the great producers in
early Hollywood had
an expression which I love,
which he said, credit you give
yourself isn't worth having.
And so, I say that as a caveat here of,
the story of the Lion King
is a reflection of something
that had happen to me in my life,
in my 20s.
And I wanted to tell that in a story,
not the Hamlet part.
That had nothing to do with.
[LAUGH] There's a guy, Willy Shake-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Something or rather, he was that.
But the notion that for
those of who may have a minor
memory of this is that
Simba believes that he was
responsible for
the death of his dad and he runs,
because he does not feel
he can confront that truth
to his mom and to his family,
and to his tribe.
And so he goes away and finds Pumba and
Timon and Hakuna Makata.
And eventually,
Nala shows up, this childhood
friend of his, and
reminds him of what's there and
then between Rafiki
shaking his magic wand and
Mufasa from up there, you must return.
>> [LAUGH]
>> He goes back and
faces his truth And
I had a situation in my life and
my career in which that happened to me,
not in the familiar way,
which I felt would be the way in
which we could all relate to it.
But there was a set of circumstances
in which everything was on the line for
me and it was a chance for
me to cut and run.
And I knew ultimately someday,
you cannot run from the truth,
the truth will find you.
And so, I made a very bold and
very hard and very difficult decision for
me to come back and face the truth and by
the way the outcome was great for me and
doing that and I just felt that was
such a life learning lesson for
me that I wanted to try and
tell that in a story.
And another movie I've made which
probably many of you don't ever know or
mabye barely heard about, which was
also a reflection of something for
me, which is about how I feel about life,
I actually don't like the word, no.
Maybe some of you do but
that doesn't work for
me, in pretty much any and
so, there was a movie
called Spirits,
Stallion of the Cimarron and
it was the last hand drawn
animated movie that I made,
as that sort of revolution
of CG came along,
Struck was the next one after it.
And it was a very, very,
it was my homage to really,
one of the great things that
I think Walt Disney did,
which was, it's to allow
animation to be it's best and
to let the pictures do
all the storytelling.
So, the lead character,
which is this indomitable character,
Spirit, he doesn't talk, right?
So there's, it relies on animation
to actually tell itself and
it is a musical and nobody sings,
other than Bryan Adams who sings
kind of sound track to it.
So it was a really incredibly ambitious,
very risky animated movie that failed.
[LAUGH] But not for me and
that story specifically of
Spirit which is, he is a character
that no matter what the circumstances,
his optimism and his determination
would not allow him to fail.
And that's me, I just have
a bottomless well of optimism and,
so and
then the third one is I grew up across
from the New York City Central Park Zoo.
And I used to go there as a young kid
five, six, seven, eight years old and
when I would see the zoo
through my eyes as
a kid, I thought well,
they live on Fifth Avenue.
I'd see they got steak everyday.
They were groomed and taken care of and
their cages were already washed and
cleaned everyday and I thought, God.
These animals,
they're living the top of the line and
I thought well, what would happen if
they had to actually go back to Africa?
And there is Madagascar.
>> It sounds like this incredibly
personal connections for
you in making these films,
the ones that really stick with you.
>> Well, the animated ones for sure but
they're great movies over the years that
are just wonderful things were great,
film makers, great storytellers,
great artists have these amazing
stories they wanted to tell.
And just to kind of be on
the sideline cheerleading them,
helping them realize those
things was just very exciting.
But I made 406 live action movies,
when I say I made,
they were made while I was,
overseeing these studios over
the years and 41 animated movies and
there's a lot.
And man,
there's just a ton of dogs in there.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] You had an abrupt departure
from Disney, can you talk to
us about what that was like?
>> Sure, so in the Summer of 1994,
the number one movie in
the world was the Lion King.
The number one Album, soundtrack or
actually record, period,
was soundtrack to Lion King,
sold 27, 28 million hard copies.
Anybody want to think about that today?
[LAUGH] How extraordinary that is.
The number one home video in the world
was from Aladdin, the year before.
The number one show on Broadway
was Beauty and the Beast.
The number one TV show was a show we
produced called Home Improvement.
The number one book on
the New York Times Best, you get the idea.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Like at a moment in time and
I don't know whether that's
happened again since or not,
maybe it has, certainly possible for
the Disney Company,
we had number 1 of every single place
that we produced for, which is pretty
much across the entire spectrum of things
that are around entertainment and culture.
I got fired.
And it was horribly ugly.
I mean, it was, I had,
we've been together with
the CEO of the company.
Michael Eisner and I, we're partners
together for 18 and a half years and
I guess the analogy I would
make except I'm fortunately and
I have not experienced this but
I have friends that have.
It's like a marriage when perfectly
two appoint and then somehow or
another just got on the line and there is
a reason for this, is that Michael and
I had this amazing marriage counselor
who was the president of the company,
amazing guy, selfless, one of the most
selfless people I've ever met,
his name is Frank Wells.
Ans so, there was Michael as
the CEO of the company and
Frank was the COO and
I was the CEO of the Walt Disney Studios.
And Frank, [COUGH] for
all of these years, 10 years,
he was the guy that always kind of made
things right between Michael and I.
And that when we would
sort of get up on the line or
at each other or I wasn't being sensitive
or not, for not being inclusive,
whatever those things are, Frank
would come in my office, sit down and
put his feet up on the table and go, I
think there's a better way of doing this.
And he managed to do that and
then quite tragically, in April of 1994,
he died in a helicopter crash.
This is where one of my partners
always said to me Jeffery,
there's your plan and there's God's
plan and your plan doesn't count.
And this is one of those moments where
suddenly everything that worked,
nothing worked.
And so Michael and
I got sideways with one another,
very quickly and
they way to became this amazing eruption.
And he fired me and
at the moment in time in which I
wasn't doing my job as well
as I had ever done it before.
And at the time, it was incredibly
public and incredibly ugly and
very personal and very nasty and it
resulted in a lawsuit and Just went on for
a really long time, and I would have
to rank that as probably my greatest
regret professionally, not that I
got fired, it's how I got fired.
And that may not make any sense to you,
but I just look
back today and there must've been a better
way for me to go about separating.
And if I could have a do over,
at least I would try and do that.
And I don't know that it would
have a different outcome.
I don't think it would, but
it would have had a better way
to get to the outcome of it.
because it's the most humiliating,
embarrassing moment of my career.
I felt just completely demeaned
by it and just hurt by it.
And it was hard.
Eight days later after getting fired,
I started DreamWorks with
David Geffen [LAUGH] so I got over
it in about seven and a half days.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Pretty quick turnaround.
>> Yes.
>> But I just hear so much love for the
films and the people involved at Disney,
and I really appreciate that
you shared all of that with us.
But you did,
you turned right around and took
an entrepreneurial leap when you could've
taken an operating role at any of the
established studios with the track record.
I mean, you'd just made
number one on every measure.
So why take the leap?
>> Well, again,
the sort of recurring thing for me and
literally going back to
those days of Lindsay and
Paramount and Disney and DreamWorks and
again here today now,
I have loved the idea of a blank slate.
I know from most people
it's a scary thing,
particularly, and
most of these almost like clockwork.
These have been ten-year
chapters in my career.
And so they're long and they're deep
roots and it's attached to people and
projects and friends and family that I
grew up within each of these chapters.
But I find that for me,
whether it's the circumstances changed,
the team broke up, or
I got fired, starting over has
always been fantastic for me.
And what has come in front of me
has always, every single time,
no matter how great the circumstances, so
as great as Paramount was for
me, or Disney was for me.
And they were fantastic times and
incredible decades there.
And so much to love and be proud of,
what came next was better.
And so when Comcast showed up a year and
a half ago,
I thought my third act was going to be
doing another ten years of DreamWorks,
and making number 407 and 42.
[LAUGH] And at first it was like,
what do you mean, you want my company,
you don't want me?
It was like, well,
I'm kind of hurt by that for a moment.
And then I thought about it, and honestly
one day, I woke up the next morning and
went, no, no, no, wait a minute.
This is a chance to be 25 years old again,
with extraordinary,
extraordinary resources and
contacts and all of these things.
And honestly, I never imagined there would
be another get to start all over again.
And the moment that that idea just came
into my head, I couldn't get it out.
I couldn't get away, and
it became more exciting to me.
And so
passing the baton to the NBC Universal
people on DreamWorks seemed like
the most obvious must do thing.
It was better for my employees because
they would be part of this $200 billion
company, have more job security and
more resources.
And these are people that have
been with me a long time and
I felt a great sense of obligation and
loyalty to them.
I could afford to take risks,
they might not.
And all of these characters in movies and
IP that we had created,
to put them in the hands of people that
could made them live forever if they so
choose to, there couldn't be a better
place or a better organization to do that.
And for the shareholders,
it was an extraordinary outcome.
Stock was selling at $21 a share,
they bought it for $41 a share.
And so I couldn't put myself in
the way of all of those three outcomes
which were better for everybody.
And then once that idea of, okay,
you can start all over again.
I went, touchdown, let's go.
>> Made it.
So you are looking into the future
with excitement in your new venture.
You are looking for
the team to pull around you.
And before we were talking,
you described building a team for
a business as a casting process.
So how are you casting for
your new venture right now?
>> Well, again,
one of the recurring things for
me over the years is I've always had great
mentors as I talked about Barry Diller,
but Michael Eisner was a great mentor.
Again, we were together for
18 and a half of those years.
It was a phenomenal partnership and
I learned so much from him.
And so I've had a series of
amazing mentors over the years.
Two people who were mentors that
went on to do something different.
Well, one, Barry Diller, and
he started this company called
IAC about 25 years ago.
And the other was John Malone and
Liberty Media.
And I saw in what they did
something that excited me,
because I'm a builder,
and I'm an operator.
I'm not an investor.
And I believe that the most
valuable thing is human capital.
To build businesses, to do things,
obviously, you need the cash
to be able to do it.
But the most valuable
thing is human capital.
And so, in starting WonderCo I
wanted to put together a partnership
of people that if the day you
were going to have a business,
either one that you were starting or
one that you already had started.
And you wanted exceptional
resources to help you take
that to some great new plateau,
that within WonderCo
we actually had everything
you would want in a C suite.
You have a great strategist,
you have a great marketing executive,
you have a general counsel,
a CFO, a COO, a CEO.
Everything that you would want in
a place like that, we got some of.
And so to have that as sort of
the resource because when I look at
Barry Diller and John Malone,
that's what they have done.
They had found companies around ideas and
around entrepreneurs, and
then they have put a ton of people
capital into those enterprises.
Diller started IAC 25 years ago.
His idea was that intersection
of the Internet and
to be able to create commercial
consumer transactions on it.
So everything from Expedia to I'm sure no
one in this room has ever actually done
anything that has anything
to do with Match.com.
[LAUGH]
So
Barry's probably built literally $70,
80, 90 billion worth of market cap.
I mean, it's like a quiet story,
not maybe that well told.
But he's literally one of the greatest
entrepreneurs of our time.
And I think right now, today,
is exactly another one of those moments.
And today that intersection is technology.
And the intersection of video.
And the application of video against,
or integrated with technology.
And how transformative and
imperative that is going to be for
what I think is the next evolutionary, if
not revolutionary part of our world today.
I'll try and maybe translate that,
which is if you go back maybe,
I don't know, 12,
14 years ago,
everybody was on a thing called a Nextel.
Most people in this room were, too.
This is you could send a text to somebody
on this little sort of pager device.
Somebody up here laughed,
it's probably over 40.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
then we went from that to a flip phone.
And you had to actually hit
three times to get an R.
I know this,
I'm speaking Swahili to you but trust me.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
then I'm now getting into territory here.
We went to a Blackberry, and
then from a Blackberry to a smartphone.
And so in a course of about 12, 14 years,
everything around text, the application
of text, the platforms around text.
So if you think about communication,
collaboration, sharing, search,
e-commerce and even entertainment.
In a very short handful of years,
text became ubiquitous,
the enterprise is built around
text became worth hundreds
of billions if not trillions of dollars.
And all of us became expert at it.
So, literally the ability of all of us and
any of us and
anyone of us to use text against
those seven verticals today,
is honestly as easy as putting
one foot in front of another.
So then about five, six years after that
happen the next thing that happen in
that sort of evolution was photography.
And so today every single one of us
is like a junior and Annie Liebowitz.
We can all take great photos no matter
how inept we are we can't help but
take great photos.
And so now think about
these in these last four or
five years now,
the impact that photography has had.
So we had moved.
And it's not displaced text,
it's added on text.
Why?
Because a picture is a thousand,
is better than a thousand words.
You've heard that said before on it.
So, now you think about communication,
collaboration, you get it.
[LAUGH] The application of
photography has been transformed and
once again many hundreds and
billions of dollars of market values.
Whether it's Instagram or Pinterest and
we can go on and on, okay?
So we're now in the third cycle.
The sort of next third evolution
is the application of video
against each of those
very specific verticals.
And you're seeing what happens
when people come along and
come up with the application of
putting these two things together.
So two perfect examples
of it are Snapchat right?
In the world of communication and sharing.
If you thinking of an entertainment
best of it is Netflix.
Netflix is people forget it, they were
again I don't know if anybody remember,
they used to have a red
envelope with a DVD in it.
That's only seven years ago.
Now, it's streaming and
a $100 billion market
cap over the intersection of video and
technology.
So for is today,
we have a team that we have build
that we think bridges that world.
And there's 12 of us,
9 of which came were graduates of
Stanford, so thank you all very much.
>> [LAUGH]
>> One
of us is not a graduate of Stanford.
He couldn't get in here, so he went
to Harvard Business School instead.
But he teaches here,
which is Sujay Jaswajoi.
He should stand up and
wave hello there because hopefully,
some of you are being taught by him today.
Come on Sujay, show that t-shirt off.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Stand up, stand up.
>> There we go.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> And so
we have a partnership that I
think is a great marriage and
collaboration between Northern California
and Southern California.
Which right now at this moment in time is
highly unique because we are different
cultures, we actually
speak different languages.
But our co-dependency on one another,
the integration of these two
worlds is literally these two trains
that are on their way at one another.
And so for Wonder Co we believe
we have the human capital
to facilitate that and to take advantage
of it and to be entrepreneurial around it.
>> An incredible vision, you seem to
have pretty boundless ambition for
what's to come and
Meg Whitman is obviously going to blend
a huge amount of experience for that.
Well, it's a perfect example,
I've known Meg for 30 years.
She's truly one of the most extraordinary
leaders and just great people.
She was on my board at
DreamWorks Animation.
We met when I was at Disney.
We've started this new business,
which is right now we as our
working title is called New TV.
But it's an incredibly, incredibly
exciting, ambitious, improbable,
likely impossible dream that she and
I now are sharing.
And it can only work by putting
our two worlds together,
and she brings just a level
of knowledge of expertise.
She's been at every, whether it's what
she did at eBay or certainly at HP.
She just has an incredible,
incredible set of skills I don't.
And it is,
I believe it is one of those things where
1 plus 1 is going to equal 11.
>> Better to see it.
I want to thank you for
everything that you shared with us so far.
We're going to pause for
a moment to open up to questions.
>> Love it.
>> And than we'll close.
>> Great.
All right, my name is David,
and I'm a second year here.
And I'm inspired by your talk of
the movement from the third, to second,
to third wave of video.
Does Wonder Co have any sort of ambitions
on saying what's after the third wave?
Well no,
because we've got to get to the third.
[LAUGH] I think we're at the beginning
of the beginning of the third wave,
but I actually think that you just
imagine what the application is.
Let me give you just one place here,
which is e-commerce.
So think of how much E-Commerce
was changed from text to photo.
Right, that the ability that you
can actually look at commerce on
your phone and see displayed for you.
Every single version sneaker
you can imagine, right?
Okay now, move to video.
And video, which is how the human being
actually functions, sight and sound.
And it is really the way in which we
ingest data in the most effective,
most efficient way and
we can put emotions around those things.
So now think about how all those versions
of Nike will look like in video.
So and I say that because we're in Mr.
Nike's home here,
>> Building.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So you can thank him for this.
So but, the application of video for
commerce is going to be transformative.
As much as we think we had a,
I would say we're in that sort of
evolutionary revolutionary moment
from retail into E-commerce.
I would bet that we'll look at five,
seven years from now,
it won't look anything like, I mean,
it'll just go to a whole another level.
By the application of video.
Just that one, and
now we can go to the other verticals and
I think it'll be as impactful.
>> I'm Arial.
I don’t know if this is on.
>> Yeah, we can hear you.
>> Great, I'm an MBA I and my question is
what you learned from your partnership
with Spielberg and Geffen and how you've
applied that into building Wonder Co and
how you'll build you future
teams within the company.
>> Well,
I mean it's amazing partnership and
I think taught me about what
the value of partnering can be.
When Stephen and Dave and
I came together in 1994.
If you went to Las Vegas, probably
as many of you are going to tonight,
you could place a bet on how long would
the three of them be able to be in
the same sandbox without
killing each other.
Right, and the odds were 100 to 1
that it would blow up in a year or
two [COUGH] but what Steven and David and
I found in each other [COUGH]
is very specific expertise.
And as partners we actually
could rely on one another.
So quite obviously in
the world of story telling,
Steven Spielberg arguably is
the greatest storyteller,
certainly among greatest
storytellers of our time.
And so
to defer to him as the sort of final
arbiter in that regard seems easy and
good to do, and even for
me who had had amazing success
before we came to that partnership.
I always felt deferential.
And even on our animated movies,
I would always bring Steven in,
I mean, right up to the very end.
Once a week, he'd come over and
give me a morning.
And I would engage him in every way and
any way.
I didn't always agree with him, but
I always wanted to hear
what he would have to say.
David Geffen, in the media space,
probably the most successful
entrepreneur of our time.
He literally made billions and billions
and billions of dollars from being
brilliant in the music business, brilliant
in Broadway, successful movie producer.
It's just, the guy has taste.
And everything he did, worked.
And so, but most of all,
a fantastic entrepreneur.
So, and I'm the builder, right.
So we had a dreamer,
an entrepreneur, and a builder.
And those three things
were just incredible, and
supportive of one another and so.
Finding that, and
being able to respect that in one another,
I thought it was a bargain, because in
1994, as I said, I had just been fired.
Steven Spielberg had won the Academy Award
in the spring of 1994 for
Schindler's List, and in June of 1994,
he put out the first Jurassic Park.
So in our world,
he had won both the Academy award and
the Bank of America award.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Something,
rarely somebody does those
two at the same time.
David Geffen had actually just
recently sold his music company for
the third or fourth time, for
another billion dollars, to Universal.
And when I got fired, I went back to
my office, I left Eisner's office,
and when I walked back to my,
I did not know this at the time,
just to give you an idea
how kind of nasty it got.
So I'm in his office, he goes well I don't
think this is going to work any longer.
Stating what at that point
was truly the obvious.
What I didn't know is
while I was in his office,
he put a press release out saying
that he had fired me, right?
So I get back to my office, and
literally I walk into my office,
and my assistant says to me,
Steven Spielberg and
Bob Zemeckis are on the phone,
and they would not hang up,
they've insisted on holding on until you
come back there in Jamaica together.
So, the three of us had made a movie
called Roger Rabbit together, and
actually had kind of a great bond and, you
know, relationship came out of that movie.
And so, I get on the phone.
And they're laughing,
they go my God, this is fantastic.
It's just great and
it's funny and I'm going, really.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Explain to
me what I'm missing here because
I'm not feeling any of this, guys.
And Bob Zemeckis,
I will give him the credit for it.
Bob Zemeckis says, you know what Geoffrey,
you should just start your own studio.
And I hung up the phone and I went,
hm, now that's a good idea.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Literally, that was the moment.
[LAUGH]
>> So we're almost out of time.
To close, I would ask you to
dig the reminiscence gene just
one more time for us on stage.
On the day of the September 11th attacks
the entire country is paralyzed,
in shock, and mourning, and
you spring into action.
You activate that sense of
personal responsibility and
you put yourself at the center.
Can you describe that moment for
us and your leadership-
>> Yeah, it It was a moment for
everybody in this country,
if not around the globe, in which I
think every single person was not only
feeling fear, but also helplessness.
And most of all, what can I do?
And I thought about that,
I felt like I have to do something,
I'm not a fireman, I'm not a policeman,
I'm not soldier,
I'm an entertainer most of all,
above all what I've tried to do my whole
life Is actually bring laughter to people.
That's been my mission.
And if you think about the movies and
the most joyful, rewarding thing for
me is to stand in the back of a theater
and hear an audience in laughter.
That's my joy and it's literally the most
beautiful thing in the world to me is to
hear laughter and
particularly the laughter of children.
And I thought okay, it would be great if
we could have a shared healing moment.
And we, my community of entertainers,
actually could do something.
And so, I had this idea of
doing a telethon that would
be a tribute to America and
the strength of our country.
And was able to do the thing I was able
to do, which is to get everybody and
anybody on the telephone and
talk them into doing something that they
never would ever think of doing or
would not likely do.
And so for the first time actually in
history, every single television station,
every cable station, every radio,
everything, for that two hours, stopped.
While the greatest and
the best entertainers, singers,
actors, spoke from the heart.
And I just, for me, when I think of all of
the wonderful things that I have been able
to do and had in my career, honestly,
nothing even comes remotely close
to that moment and that time.
In which I felt it was
the ultimate unifying,
shared moment and just for a second,
I felt maybe there was, at this tragic,
tragic time, happiness.
>> Thank you so much for the gifts that
you've given us over an incredible career.
And today,
in this auditorium, we are so blessed
to hear your lessons on leadership.
>> Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]